>>> RUSSIAN FOES ARE
UNLEASHING HELL IN THEORT CITY
OF MARIUPO
THE U.S. DEFENSE OFFICIALS SAY
THE RUSSIANS ARE FIRING ON THE
CITY FROM SHIPS NOW.
LOOK AT THAT.
FROM THE SEA OF AZOV.
THIS IS VIDEO SHOWING CRUISE
MISSILES BEING LAUNCHED OFF THE
COAST, JOHN.
>> AND NEW DRONE VIDEO SHOWS THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS.
U.S. DEFENSE OFFICIALS NOW SAY
THERE IS CLEAR EVIDENCE RUSSIA
IS INTENTIONALLY TARGETING
CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE IN
UKRAINE, AND COMMITTING WAR
CRIMES.
CNN PENTAGON CORRESPONDENT
BARBARA STARR JOINS US NOW.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THAT?
>> THE U.S. PICKING ITS WORDS
VERY CAREFULLY, VERY
DELIBERATELY, SAYING THAT THEY
DO SEE NOW CLEAR EVIDENCE,
DELIBERATE AND INTENTIONAL
TARGETING OF CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE, SHELTERS,
HOSPITALS, WHERE CIVILIANS ARE
ALL ACROSS UKRAINE BY RUSSIAN
FORCES.
AND THE REASON THEY'RE BEING SO
CAREFUL WITH THIS IS THEY ARE
TRYING TO ASSEMBLE THE
INTERNATIONAL CASE BEFORE ANY --
FUTURE INTERNATIONAL COURT WHERE
WAR CRIMES CHARGES POTENTIALLY
COULD BE BROUGHT.
THEY NEED TO ASSEMBLE ALL THE
EVIDENCE THEY CAN AT THIS POINT.
THE PENTAGON PRESS SECRETARY
JOHN KIRBY EXPLAINED A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THIS.
>> CLEARLY THERE ARE CIVILIAN
CASUALTIES AND CLEARLY THEY ARE
MOUNTING EVERY DAY BECAUSE OF
THE INDISCRIMINATE ATTACKS THAT
THE RUSSIANS ARE CONDUCTING.
WE BELIEVE WE SHOULD CALL IT
LIKE WE SEE IT AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE ARE CARR CRI WAR CRI
CONDUCTED RUSSIAN THE RUSSIAN
ARMED FORCES.
>> THE U.S. IS LOOKING AT
IMAGERY, INTELLIGENCE, SOCIAL
MEDIA WE ALL SEE, BUT OTHER
THINGS THEY KNOW ABOUT TO
ASSEMBLE THAT PORTFOLIO OF
EVIDENCE.
ALL OF THAT IS GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
AS FOR RUSSIAN FORCES, WELL, THE
U.S. SAYS THEY CONTINUE TO
SUFFER FROM SHORTAGES OF FOOD,
FUEL AND SOME RUSSIAN TROOPS NOW
EVEN SUFFERING FROM FROSTBITE IN
THIS COLD WEATHER BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE APPROPRIATE GEAR.
JOHN, POPPY?
>> BARBARA STARR AT THE
PENTAGON, THANK YOU.
>>> WANT TO BRING IN CNN
MILITARY ANALYST AND RETIRED
ARMY MAJOR GENERAL JAMES
"SPIDER" MARKS.
HE'S CURRENTLY HEAD OF
GEOPOLITICAL STRATEGY AT ACADEMY
SECURITIES.
GREAT TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING.
WE KEEP HEARING REPORTS OF
UKRAINIAN COUNTEROFFENSIVES,
ESPECIALLY AROUND KYIV.
AN AIDE TO PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
SAID, I CONFIRM WE ARE MAKING
PROGRESS.
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK THAT
MEANS AND THE SIGNIFICANCE.
>> IT IS HUGELY SIGNIFICANT.
YOU LOOK AT THE MAP YOU CAN SEE
WHERE THE ADVANCES BY THE
UKRAINIAN FORCES TO THE NORTH
AND WEST OF KYIV AS THEY PUSH
BACK THAT RED AREA, WHICH IS
WHERE THE RUSSIAN FORCES HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN.
AND THEY NOW HAVE LIBERATED THE
TOWN OF MAKARIV.
AND THEN YOU LOOK TO THE EAST,
AND YOU SEE THERE HAS BEEN
LITTLE ADVANCE IN TERMS OF THAT
RUSSIAN PUSH TOWARD KYIV AND
THEN TRYING TO CROSS THE -- TO
BEGIN THE SIEGE OF KYIV.
THERE HAS BEEN AN INTELLIGENCE
REPORT THAT JUST CAME OUT, I
THINK IT IS A BRITISH
INTELLIGENCE REPORT, THAT SAYS
IT LOOK LIKE THE ANALYSIS IS, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE SOURCE IS,
BUT IT SAYS THE ANALYSIS IS IT
LOOKS LIKE THE RUSSIANS ARE
GOING TO DOUBLE DOWN IN TERMS OF
BEGINNING THEIR ASSAULT ON KYIV.
I DON'T SEE IT THAT WAY.
FRANKLY, BECAUSE YOU DON'T -- AS
A MILITARY -- WANT TO REINFORCE
FAILURE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO PUT GOOD MONEY
AFTER BAD.
I WOULD SEE WHAT THEY'RE DOING
ALONG THE BLACK SEA COAST, AND
THE CITY OF MARIUPOL AND KHERSON
IS WHERE THE RUSSIANS WANT TO
TRY TO GAIN SOME TYPE OF
ADDITIONAL --
>> YOU MAKE AN IMPORTANT POINT
IN THEIR ATTEMPT TO BASICALLY
BUILD A LAND BRIDGE OR TAKE A
LAND BRIDGE THERE.
IF WE COULD TALK ABOUT MARIUPOL
AND THE DESTRUCTION, LET'S SHOW
AGAIN CONTROL ROOM IF WE COULD
JUST THAT HEART BREAKING,
DEVASTATING FOOTAGE, NEW AERIAL
FOOTAGE FROM THE AZOV BATTALION
REVEALS THE EXTENT OF DAMAGE,
YOU SAW IT A MOMENT AGO, NOW
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THESE -- THERE
IS THE DAMAGE AND THEN YOU SAW
THE IMAGES OF THE SHOTS BEING
FIRED FROM THE SEA.
IF RUSSIA IS UNLEASHING AN
ASSAULT ON THIS CITY FROM THE
SEA OF AZOV, WHAT -- WHAT MORE
CAN BE DONE TO DEFEND MARIUPOL?
>> WELL, LOOKS LIKE THERE IS
NOTHING TO DEFEND.
I FIND THIS STRATEGICALLY
ILLOGICAL.
WHAT IS PUTIN TRYING TO ACHIEVE?
IF YOU WANT TO ACHIEVE SUCCESS,
WHAT IS YOUR IN STATE DESIRE?
LOOK AT THIS IMAGE.
IT IS TO LEVEL THE THING AND
JUST BURN EVERYTHING OUT AND IT
HAS NO CITIZENS.
WHAT STRATEGIC VALUE IS THAT?
I CANNOT GET MY HEAD AROUND WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE, OTHER
THAN THIS IS JUST WAR
CRIMINALITY.
I WOULD GO TO JOHN KIRBY AND SAY
TAKE THE GLOVES OFF, BROTHER,
AND CALL IT WHAT IT IS.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY CRIMINAL,
BRUTAL BEHAVIOR.
I UNDERSTAND WE GOT TO WALK
THIS, DO THIS LITTLE DANCE, WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL COURTS.
I GOT IT.
I'M NOT A LAWYER.
BUT I'M LOOKING AT THIS AND I
SEE -- LET'S CALL IT WHAT IT IS
AND GET ENTIRELY BEHIND THE
EFFORT TO CALL OUT THE
LEADERSHIP, STARTING WITH PUTIN
AND WALKING THROUGH HIS
ORGANIZATION IN TERMS OF WHERE
THOSE CRIMINALS RESIDE AND LET'S
GET THEM, GET THEM INDICTED.
>> SO, SPIDER, U.S. AND NATO
OFFICIALS TELL CNN THEY SEE
SIGNS THAT BELARUS IS LOOKING TO
JOIN THE WAR HERE.
AND PERHAPS SEND THEIR OWN
TROOPS OVER THE BORDER.
I WAS SPEAKING TO UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS BEFORE WHO DIDN'T
FRANKLY SEEM THAT WORRIED ABOUT
THAT.
WHAT KIND OF DIFFERENCE WOULD IT
MAKE?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW THAT IT
WOULD REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE,
FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T THINK
LUKASHENKO HAS A VOTE IN THIS
ISSUE TO COMMIT HIS FORCES.
HE DANCES TO THE TUNE THAT IS
ESTABLISHED BY PUTIN.
BUT WHAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
HERE IS WHEN YOU PUT ADDITIONAL
FORCES IN ON OTHER FORCES THAT
HAVE NOT AS A MATTER OF ROUTINE
BEEN WORKING TOGETHER AND
TRAINING TOGETHER VERY DEEPLY,
NOW, CLEARLY ABOUT A MONTH AND A
HALF AGO THEY WERE DOING
EXERCISES, I DON'T KNOW THEIR
INTERACTION IN BELARUS, BUT THIS
COULD BE NEGATIVE VALUE WHEN YOU
START BRINGING IN NEW FORCES,
YOU HAVEN'T ESTABLISHED THE
BATTLE SPACE, YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO DO
AND YOU START TO PLUG GAPS AND
THE RUSSIANS ARE ALREADY DEALING
WITH COMMAND AND CONTROL ISSUES.
NOW YOU'VE GOT THIS OTHER GANG
OF DUDES, YOU HAVE NO CLUE WHAT
THEIR PROFESSIONALISM LOOKS LIKE
AND YOU'RE THROWING THEM INTO
THE FIGHT.
THIS COULD BE AN INCREDIBLE MESS